hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast advanced flow cytometry
analysis of human t-cell memory subset
i'm judy or oracle Everts and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by Beckman
Coulter life sciences Beckman Coulter
develops manufactures and markets
products that simplify automate and
innovate complex biomedical testing more
than 270 tel gives me more than two
hundred and seventy-five thousand
Beckman culture systems operate in both
diagnostics and life sciences
Laboratories on seven continents for 80
years Beckman cultures products have
been making a difference in people's
lives
by improving the productivity of medical
professionals and scientists supplying
critical information for improving
patient health and delivering trusted
solutions for research and discovery for
more information please visit Beckman
Coulter comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and you encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem to the green screen a
button lower left I would now like
introduce today's speaker dr. Nicole
Wyatt
dr. Wyatt works for Beckman Coulter life
sciences as a senior application
scientist together with her team she
supports and provides guidance to
customers in their transition to higher
complexity by cometary applications in
the fields of both clinical and research
related applications I will now turn
this over to dr. Nicole Wyatt for her
presentation Thanks
Julie for the nice introduction and
thanks everyone for logging in today in
this webinar I'm going to start by
giving you an overview over the models
that are currently used to describe Pisa
memory subsets I will also explain to
you the marker selection we used for our
13 color t-cell subset analysis and that
will outline the rationale we had for
our choice of fluorochromes finally I
will show you some real-life flow data
and I will describe also the gating
strategy for you all all the reagents
and instruments used for this work after
research use only so T lymphocytes
developed from bone marrow derived
precursors most of the developmental
steps occur in the thymus where P cells
are selected for the ability to
recognize antigen presented by self MHC
molecule but where at the same time
cells that react too strongly to self
MHC are also selected again to avoid
autoimmunity at the end of confinement
is our differential differentiation path
we have three major G's or subsets cd8
positive cytotoxic t-cells cd4 positive
T helper cells and also cd4 positive
cd25 bright regulatory T cells these
cells then leave the sinus and enter the
peripheral blood and other peripheral
tissues as recent clinic immigrants
these cells are purely naive and that
they have never encountered antigen and
as a mature cell have never undergone
from the fruitive processes once these
cells encounter their specific antigen
in the periphery under the correct
co-stimulatory conditions
they start to proliferate and to
differentiate towards different t-cell
effector subsets effector T cells can
most efficiently be described based on
the cytokines they produce while
cytotoxic T cells also mediate effects
by direct cell mediated targets are
killing all cd8 positive cytotoxic T
cells and cd4 positive health of cells
and regulatory t-cells use the release
of cytokines to influence the tissues
around them and all other immune cells
unfortunately the Indian phenotype with
respect to for example hemo kine
receptor expression is not very
informative when we want to draw
conclusions about the character or the
subtype of an effector T so therefore
it's best to directly assess the what
cytokine is produced by a cell if we
want to classify it so cd8 positive T
cells mainly produce antiviral
interferon gamma vile the suppressant
activity of regulatory t-cells is mainly
mediated by introducing 10 and TG is
better for the helper T cell subset it
gets more interesting here we have the
classical th1 and th2 cells the th1
cells characterized by interferon gamma
production the ph2 cells producing il-4
and mainly providing b-cell health these
have been go known for a very long time
in recent years other effector helper
cell subsets were described also based
on their intelligent production
follicular helper t-cells mainly produce
interleukin 21 and
crucial for the germinal center
formation and function th17 cells which
are depicted in the lower right hand
corner are important for the activation
of neutrophils in defense of
extracellular bacteria but they have
also been implicated in autoimmune
phenomenon cd20 two cells which are
shown in the middle in the bottom in the
middle play an important role in
epithelial innate immune response and
also in epithelial repair mechanisms and
the most recently described subset th9
cells only three mostly producing
interleukin nine play an important role
in regulating allergy and other
autoimmune responses and also have been
implicated in tumor tumor immunity at
the end of an immune response when the
pathogen has been eliminated most of the
affected cells are removed from the
organism to retain immune system
homeostasis however in order to confer
long term protection against already
encountered pathogens T cell memory
plays an important role
so after encounters an antigen not only
effector T cells develop but there's
also the generation of memory T cells at
the moment it is unclear whether this is
a sequential differentiation step or if
there are different differentiation
pathways towards an effector T cell fate
or a memory T cell faint with regard to
memory T cells we define them as cells
that have undergone proliferation either
in response to antigen recognition or
also as a response to homeostatic
proliferation stimuli this is important
to
abroad Pisa repertoire during the
lifetime of a person or an organism when
we want to define memory T's or subsets
it's easier than for effective selves
because for memory T cells gene
phenotype is very informative
the first markers that have been used to
distinguish between naive and antigen
experience memory T cells were the cd45
isoforms are a four-night yeast cells
and ro for memory T cells in 1999
federico solutio expanded this few and
managed to identify subsets of memory T
cells namely central memory and effector
memory T cells by including ccr7 into
the mix and naive t-cells expresses both
ccr7 and cd45 RA as shown in the dot
plot in the right on the right hand side
of the slides and here the naive cells
are depicted as the double positive in
the upper right hand corner upon
encounter of antigen and proliferation
cd45 RA expression is lost and for the
cells that retain ccr7 expression we
describe them a central memory T cells
ccr7 and chemokine receptor is crucial
for the ability of these cells to home
to central and fluid organs central
memory T cells are also characterized by
high proliferative potential however for
them to display any kind of effective
functions like cytokine production they
need a couple of even days after E
stimulation cells that have lost both
ccr7 expression and cd45 are eggs
are called effector memory T cells these
cells show a very rapid cytokine
production within a couple of hours of
after East emulation these cells also
have shorter telomeres than central
memory sub central memory T cells and
therefore they have a lower
proliferative potential due to the loss
of ccr7 they also don't home to
secondary lymphoid organs but they
preferentially home to inflamed tissue
within the cd8 positive T cell
compartment we can further differentiate
so-called p.m. raw cells these a memory
T cells that have either retained or
reacquired the expression of cd4 t v ra
and it is known that these cells have a
very high cytotoxic potential in 2002
the lab of dr. PI described the use of
CD 27 and cd28 to further describe the
differentiation of cd8 positive
cytotoxic t-cells they could show that
upon repeated cell division the upon
repeated cell divisions the expression
of cd28 was first lost so they
characterized cells that have lost cd28
but still expressed CD 23 as
intermediate cytotoxic t-cells only
later after even more cell divisions
2627 is also lost and we're talking
about late t-cells so if you're looking
at the dot plot on the left hand side in
the apple panel you can see the
differentiation pathway from early cd8
positive T cells expressing both 27 and
twenty-eight than the loss of cd28 and
also the loss of CD 27 for the double
negative cells it is known that deja are
reduced to linear function which is
indicative of replicative senescence and
this is an irreversible cell cycle
arrest other markers to further
characterize terminally differentiated
cd8 plus cells include PD 1 or
programmed cell death 1 which is mainly
expressed on effector memory cells and
if said to the amarka for reversible
t-cell exhaustion after persistent
antigen exposure these cells are still
able to produce immune responses but
their affective functions are much less
robust than for less differentiated
cells CD 23:57 sorry is mainly expressed
on camera cells and is a marker of
replicative senescence cells expressing
pd 1 and CD 57 are said to have a higher
cytotoxic function and still show
cytokine production even though they are
no longer able to show a robust
proliferative response together with
Matias tribes from the SHA VT in Berlin
and the one study group who looked at
Indian monitoring after solid organ
transplantation we designed a dry direct
own leg bone panel to identify memory T
cell subsets so we included cd45 as a
leukocyte marker to be able to better
differentiate to differentiate the
lymphocytes we have a backbone of the 3
4 and H to identify
the basic t-cell substance we're using
cd45 RA and ccr7
to discriminate between naive central
memory effector memory and TMR cells and
we included CD 27 and cd28 in order to
see early intermediate and late
cytotoxic T cell differentiation and we
included CD 57 and pd1 for markers of
proliferative senescence and t-cell
exhaustion respectively in order to make
our panel more largely applicable and
also because we had a certain color
instrument we added more markers as
liquid robins we decided to add cd25 and
CD 127 to be able to distinguish
regulatory t-cells and together with
cd45 RA expression we can stink
distinguished naive natural t-rex vs
antigen experienced memory t-rex which
is said to have a higher suppressive
capacity to fill the last slot in our
antigen panel we decided to add CD 95
because we wanted to identify stem
cell-like t-cells the subset was first
described in 2011 by the lab of Luca
gotten Oni and they showed that there is
a self renewing t-cell substance with a
very high proliferative potential they
could show that these cells also have
the ability to differentiate towards
different effector subsets and
that they are highly effective in
controlling tumor burden in mouse models
these cells shall mainly net HP for
markers like CCO 7ra ACD 27 28 127 but
interestingly they are also defined by a
high CD 95 expression so why are these
cells interesting to us and might also
be interesting to some of you so only
recently looking at the ESCO published a
paper where he showed that these cells
can survive up to 12 years in humans
after transplantation and this makes the
stem cell-like t-cell subset very
interesting for use in gene therapy
approaches so when we thought about
combining all these markers into one
channel we took into account the dye
performance characteristic the spectra
overlap but also the co-expression
patterns on the cells we expected and I
would like to take this chance now to
send a question out to you guys to see
how many colors you're using for your
flow analysis so you should have
received the question and if you could
now just please indicate if you're using
one two five colors six to ten for more
complex analysis or if your routine
using more than ten colors I'll give you
a little while longer to submit your
answers
okay
so it looks like almost 50% of you are
using six to ten colors around 40% are
running lower complexity essays with one
to five colors and around 15% are using
more than ten colors so for those of you
running more than eight colors I guess
you already have experience how
difficult it can be to design a good and
sensitive panels where you retain
sensitivity fordham antigens and
especially to have you know type
independent detection limits so the main
goal for us with this recent memory
panel was to have a marquee selection
where we had the same detection limits
for the cd8 and the city for subsets and
of course it's always desirable to have
a robust compensation metrics so in an
ideal world we would just use four
colors distribute them evenly on the
three lasers we had available and run
our panels without any compensation
however since we wanted to run a way
more complex panel we had to face the
reality of multicolor flow cytometry so
the main issue which also makes panel
design complex is cross talk between
different fluorescent channels and the
Associated data spread so here we have a
little example of that we have an e CD
singles
ticket on the x-axis and fluorescence
channel 3 and we plot on the left hand
side ECD versus the key channel FL 2 on
the right hand side we depicted BCG
versus the PSI 7 forage channels FL 5 we
set the cytometer settings and the
detector settings in a way that both
channels require about 15% of
compensation versus you GCD so when we
apply those 15% of compensation we can
see that the population especially for
the PSI 7 channel spreads this is due to
the increased standard deviation which
causes an increased broadness of
distribution in the far red channel
based on the lower energy of the light
signals we detect in those channels and
this more dramatically and more relevant
to ask us results in a loss of
sensitivity so now the smaller red
rectangle I drew these cells in there
they're by no means dimly positive for
psi 7 this is background caused by a
bright ECG signal and
sorry this will result in decreased
sensitivity in the otherwise quite
bright and sensitive psi 7 channel when
we compare fluorochromes they're not all
created equal so we have fluorochromes
like nowadays fitzy or Chrome Orange
which are quite dim we also have with PE
and a PC fluorochromes that give us a
quite bright signal however especially
when working in a multicolor panel
brighter isn't always better dye
brightness is actually an ambiguous dye
property so here we have an example
where we stained in the upper panel with
ECD in the lower panel we stained the
same marker with chrome orange so you
you can see at first glance the ECD
gives you a much better distribution our
distinction between positive and
negative B is much brighter in this case
however for the Chrome orange you can
still distinguish the positive cells
from the negative ones on the y-axis
from left to right we have plotted
fluorescence channel 115 channel if L 2
are the P channel FL 3 sorry FL for the
PSI 5.5 channel and on the very right
hand side FL v 2 psi 7 channel and what
you can see that for the better
resolution you get with the ECD stain
you pay with a loss of sensitivity in
the PE PC 5.5 and PSI 7 channels so
there is a trade-off also to dye
brightness
for often it's better to use a diet that
is just bright enough to see the cells
that you can see but will not influence
the neighboring channels these crosstalk
effects can be visualized using a chart
so this chart is instrument specific
based on laser and filter combination
for this one you can see right now once
developed for the gaudiest nevia's flow
cytometry platforms but you can also use
it as an orientation for your own
instrument so this should be read from
the top down so for easy D for example
you can see there is a little spill over
in the PE channel there is even more
spill over in the PC 5 and PC 5.5
channels and then it goes down again
using this we can distinguish so-called
silent fluorochromes that do not
influence any of the neighboring
channels and therefore might be a good
choice for bright markers and we can
also identify so-called untouchable
channels that are only marginally
affected by bright signals in the
neighboring channels as I just said this
charge isn't applicable for every
instrument here we have the gallio's as
an example on the right hand side where
the cd4 key staining and we plotted cd4
on the x axis versus the PSI 5.5 channel
and you can see a considerable amount of
data spread I will just mark this
in a box for you when we compare the
gallio's which is a classical flow
cytometer using photomultiplier tubes
with a modern more modern platform to
Saito flex which uses Avalanche
photodiodes we see that on that on the
side of flex I will also mark this in
red the data spread is much less
pronounced there's a much lower standard
deviation as the Everland photodiodes
are much more effectively detecting
photons within the far-red wavelength
area it's always good to know your
instruments when you want to design
panels what we also took into account
besides the instrument and the flora
chrome characteristic were the
expression patterns so if you have the
chance because you're working with
markers that have already been described
it's always good to know
to see which antigens are modulated in a
sense that there is a continuous
expression ranging from absent too dim
to bright which markers show a discrete
expression and also it's good to know
which markers are mutually exclusive and
what can be true expressed taking all
this into account we described a number
of rules there are more rules of thumb
and hard and fast rules so we call it
old-school
of course we still start by combining
weakly expressed antigens with bright
dyes and vice-versa
however we also take into account that
weakly express antigens work best and
channels that are not affected by data
spread and crosstalk
from neighboring channels so we might
still combine the not so bright Pacific
blue with an activation marker why we
try to put strongly expressed antigens
together with dyes that are silent we
can accept a certain amount of spillover
between mutually exclusive antigens like
cd4 and cd8 for example that we should
avoid spillover if we expect that there
is a co expression and especially if one
of the markers is modulated so this
would go for an activation marker for
example we should avoid spillover from a
gating marker into an activation marker
the parent descendant role rule tells us
that if the sub set marker shows
crosstalk into the gating marker we can
allow for that that is okay so for
example if the cd4 shows a strong
spillover in the CD 3 we will never know
because the cd4 positive T cells I see
the three positive anyway the positive
threshold rule asks us to think about
what we really need to be able to define
so we can allow more spillover if we're
only interested to see the brightly
positive cells so if we only want to
gauge bright versus dim or negative then
we can accept more spillover than for
cases where we need to be able to
distinguish between negatives and dimly
positive cells and last but not least we
should always try to make our
compensation matrix as easy as possible
and minimize complexity so for the T
cell memory panel we decided to combine
the cd45 leukocyte marker with the dim
and so-called silent chrome orange dye
it's still bright enough to allow us to
discriminate the leukocytes from debris
and we can still get a clear lymph Aid
and it's not contaminated by battle
cells by using this combination we
preserve the sensitivity in all the
other channels so for the cheetah
markers we decided to make a so-called
silent backbone by placing the cd3 cd4
and cd8 all on the red laser these are
channels and fluorochromes that strongly
influence each other which we could
tolerate based on the mutual exclusion
of cd4 and cd8 we could also tolerate a
spillover from the subset markers cd4
and cd8 into the cd3 channel and by
doing this we avoid any spillover from
the cd4 or cd8 into other channels so we
will have to say in detection limits for
the cytotoxic and helper t-cell subsets
and this of course again serves our
objectives for the first naive our
memory marker cd45 RA we decided to use
fitzy as this module agent antigen
therefore we used a channel that is not
influenced by other markers cd45 RA is
also
sufficiently bright so we could combine
it with a rather dim floral chrome and
this will also avoid having any negative
influences from the cd45 are a bright
cells to further differentiate between
the east and Hector cells we added ccr7
as a PE conjugate so there is little
crosstalk between Sid C and PE on modern
digital saito meters we also have with
PE a bright pure chrome for a chemokine
receptor which are usually not so easy
to stain for on the right hand side we
can see the cd8 positive T cells in
brown with cd4 positive T cells in green
and we can nicely see that the detection
limits for CD 27 and cd28 other book are
the same for both subpopulations and for
CD 28 and ccr7 we also observed the
parent descendant rule where as ccr7
positive cells are usually CD 20
thousand 829 cd28 positive anyway for
the
Nitori t-cells we decided to put cd28 or
combine it with brilliant violet 6:15
now this wouldn't be a suitable
combination if we had wanted to use cd25
as an activation marker and there is
some degree of spillover from the city
for adding marker into the BV 650
channel but we were still nicely able to
discriminate the cd25 bright regulatory
t-cells versus all other cells when we
then placed the CD 127 interleukin 7
receptor subunit in the brilliant violet
780 channel we looked at the co
expression patterns and as we were
looking for cells that were cd25 bright
CD 127 negative we could accept that
there is spillover off the CD 127
positive cells into the 325 channel
because we were not interested in these
cells for this panel anyway
now the following data were all acquired
on the side of flex we used three out of
four available lasers of blue red and
violet lasers and used 30 in
fluorescence detectors most of the
reagents were based on a direct loan dry
reagent technology so this is not a liar
ization but it's a drying process that
will give you 10 encore new Goods and
antibody cocktails that are stable for
up to a year at room temperature and
since the cocktail has already dried
into the tube it's dramatically
minimizes sample prep time so
we first started our gating by looking
at cd45 versus flight schedule to
identify the lymphocytes based on their
bride cd45 expression and row side
scatter we then looked at cd3 expression
getting on the CD three positive lymph
aside and then went on to look at cd4
versus CD 9 to identify helper T cells
and cytotoxic T cells respectively we
then went on with our analysis looking
at the cd4 positive helper T cell
subsets on the left hand side you can
see a plot showing cd4 on the x-axis
cd25 on the y-axis we already drew a
little gate around the CD fordham cd25
bride population so that in the
following plots the regulatory t-cells
would show up in black and we also added
a gauge cd4 plus CD 25 plus and for all
the cells in the blue gate we then on
the right-hand side looked at CD 127
expression verses cd45 RA you can see
here the CD 127 bryant cells these are
effector T cells that we still have here
in our gate and we have in black 2 CD
127 themselves and those that are 345
are a positive can be considered naive
regulatory t-cells those in the lower
left quadrant are considered to be
regulatory t-cells that already have
undergone a proliferative process we
then went on to look at the cd45 ra and
ccr7 expression on the different t-cell
subsets and you can see here very nicely
on the left-hand side we have gated on
the cd4 positive T helper cells on the
right hand side we have dated only on
the cd8 positive cytotoxic T cells and
you can see that the expression patterns
of these naive in memory markers look
quite different depending on the seesaw
compartment you're looking at so for
example the helper T cells show
especially the central memory T cells
show a higher expression level of ccr7
you can also see that effector memory T
cells are mainly found in the eight
positive compartment while CD and while
TM rah are exclusively found in the cd8
positive compartment
in the next step we are focusing on
cytotoxic t-cells on the left hand side
as a reminder you again see 45 RA versus
ccr7 plot here we labeled the naive
cytotoxic t-cells in green in the upper
right quadrant we have the central
memory cells in orange in the upper left
quadrant effector memory cells in brown
in the lower left quadrant TMR cells in
a dark purple in the lower right
quadrant and then when we when you have
a look at the plot in the middle you can
see CD 27 on the x axis CD 28 on the y
axis you can see very nicely
that both naive and central memory
t-cells our CD 27 and cd28 double
positive while the central memory
t-cells show an increased expression
level of cd28 we can then follow the
differentiation pathway and observe the
laws of cd28 followed by a loss of CD 27
when we look at the right hand side we
can see very nicely that naive t-cells
shown in green Express neither CD 57 to
a great extent nor CD 1 which is here
labeled as CD 297 at 79 we can see that
the central memory T cells do acquire PD
1 expression we can see that the
exhausted t-cell subset that also
Express of CD 57 a marker for
replicative senescence
mainly consists of effector memory
t-cells and you can see the TM are cells
that are mainly CD 57 positive in the
lower right
so moving on to the last and most
elusive subset we were looking at in
order to identify stem cell-like memory
cell t-cells we first identified for
both the cd4 and cd8 positive T cells
cells that Express RA and ccr7 for all
the naive cells we then looked at the
cells shown in the middle panel and
gated on only see 27 and cd28 double
positive you can see here that this is
mainly what makes up the RA ccr7 double
positive naive cell gate anyway and then
we moved on to see how many cells of the
RAC cs7 2728 positives also had high
levels of the first molecule CD 95 so
if you would like to look at the data in
more detail read up a little bit we have
shown this as presentative as a poster
on site of this year and you can also
download the application note from our
home page we will send out a link to you
so you know exactly where you can find
any additional information so at this
point I would like to thank also my
colleagues to come back dr. micha Pinsky
and dr. andreas bloomer who were
involved in putting together the
material designing the panel and
organizing the acquisition of the data
so now I would be at the end of my
presentation and hand over to Judy thank
you dr. Wright for that informative
presentation so before we get started on
the question-and-answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how does the NIT
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and our
first question is how does human
polymorphism in a panel cell markers
that consistent antibody binding for
example is every human sample cd8 cd4
etc the same in terms of antibody
binding so it's never possible to fully
rule out any effects of different
genotypes so for most of the population
especially with the antibody clones we
used here you will find will be able to
detect the expression of the basic
markers
especially for cd8 there are 2 chainz
either an alpha and a beta chain and
there are cd8 subsets that only Express
the Alpha chain for these to catch those
you would have to use a different cd8
clone but from our experience for the
markers we used there are no known
polymorphisms that would affect the
detection of the cell sometimes um you
did not mention CD 127 as a t red marker
in your introduction is this an
established marker yeah so when t regs
were first described starting off with
cd4 jum's
e 25 fried later on it was shown that
also the lack of CD 127 could be used of
course still the gold standard would be
to stain intracellularly for Fox p3 as a
transcription factor we did not include
Fox p3 in our panel as we wanted to keep
it and as a quick surface stain only but
adding CD 127 to your panel in addition
to cd4 and cd8 when t5 will allow you to
better identify the regulatory t-cells
if you have a die spell over with a
bright or Chrome can you just dilute
your antibody further to prevent
spillover the spillover is independent
of the expression density of your
antigen so
the spillover is a characteristic of the
floral chrome you could dilute your
antibody to make your signal dimmer so
the spillover is less obvious however if
you work in an antibody range where you
don't saturate all antigen on the cell
you also run the risk of losing dimly
positive cells so if you want to do this
you need to be very careful about it and
I would recommend avoiding having to do
this if possible for the panel design in
queue it appears more questions or
convenient so I'm going to pause for
just a moment to allow them to come
through the system and search another
one to you what is the recommended
number of events to collect when running
in h13 color flow channel so this will
always depend on the population you want
to detect with the lowest frequency
usually what you want to have also when
we're thinking about detection of
minimal residual disease for example you
want to have in a at least 15 to 100
events in a cluster for the least
frequent population so for our panel
this would mean looking at the frequency
of stem cell like yourself and then
calculating from this on how many cells
we want to acquire in children to use
isotopes or SMOS controls for gating
we did not use either type controls as
just mixing 13 either types won't help
you with gating for the panel we showed
here we did not run the ethanol controls
as we felt fairly comfortable based on
the known expression patterns to be able
to discriminate the population however I
think especially for the CD 95 it would
be a good idea and also if you wanted to
use click or to make more use of the CD
25 if you not only want to discriminate
the regulatory T cells but also have a
look for the activated T cell it would
be good to run the relevant ethanol
controls okay thank you more questions
convenience I'm just going to give this
just in a moment you should send them
along Canada technique used for
analyzing T um you will need to
interpret this one can the technique be
used for analyzing Mouse memory T so the
expression patterns are there are
different markers used therefore it
would not be possible to directly use
this panel for a murren model
I did not see use of viability died do
you recommend using it always so we did
not use it because we had access to
fresh samples if you know you're going
to analyze samples that have been
shipped for example by mail or if you're
using samples from patients that are
undergoing treatment so where there is a
risk of the cells dying faster from the
treatment then it would be certainly a
good idea to add a life that's trained
you
and we're going to pause another second
um I did not see that one sorry and I
think I see that there are more
questions coming in but they can be
answered by a speaker at after the
presentation so I would once again like
to thank dr. Wyatt for her presentation
and dr. Wyatt do you have any final
comments for us so I think we covered a
lot of content today because it will be
best to let it settle if you have any
more questions please don't hesitate to
reach out and you also got the link
where you can find more information so
and I'm also willing to be in touch
enough answer questions later on and
thank you very much for attending
thank you dr. Wyatt I would also like to
thank our sponsor Beckman Coulter life
sciences for making today's educational
webcast possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May 5th 2016 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay and
we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time bye